first of all my Jew is always out I mean
like I wear this thing right here this
yarmulke
don't talk anak we're gonna lose your
Jew powers exactly for those two seconds
right there I was vulnerable but
fortunately I'm in the protection of my
protocols of the Elders like a tea
kettle where you take it on the steam
goes out only it's pure cash for the
Jews well that's why I only take it off
in the privacy of my own home I don't
wanna share that cash no of course not
so glad to bring on our next guest we
finally have him on and he's a lawyer
scholar and a gentleman ben shapiro glad
to have you with us yeah glad to be here
just sorry I can't see Stephen because
that was gonna make my evening yes of
course I know well right now I have this
horrible homeless beard and not gay
Jared's going to be fired of course for
the technical difficulties you know it's
funny Ben we've had so many requests for
you to be on like well I haven't I'm
gonna actually Ben Shapiro was on this
show before it was a show when it was
just a YouTube channel you were on to
talk about primetime propaganda I
remember that oh yeah I mean Stephen you
and I go all the way back to you
actually trying out your Brazilian head
locks on me in my con and you had a
hernia I did have a yard is the second
gayest thing
well that's because you well know what
ended up being gay is you went with krav
maga instead which is just talking about
this today I have been getting just a
rash of anti-semitic comments and I and
I'm not Jewish if you worry you'd
automatically be the center on the
Jewish basketball teams like Gary Gulman
has that bit about Tomah had a
reinforced room at the Jewish cultural
center
he's like there have been two broken
rims in the history of the NBA and not
one from a four foot and I on Jewish boy
have you been getting have you noticed a
big uptick in this oh my god well it
really only started when I started
becoming critical of Trump so my
original view of Trump was that he
wasn't conservative but he was hitting
some of the right people so I was
enjoying him hitting a lot of part I
remember that I remember that I'm her
being like what thinking it was odd
because I I said those same things but
you seemed more emphatically Pro Trump
but there's one thing to say Trump
wasn't conservative totally agreed but
some of the hits on Trump
we're illegitimate and so I sort of try
to at least be objective enough to take
out media hits on whichever candidate I
mean I mean when they went after ben
Carson for example over the West Point
thing I was the one who really
the West Point store right and that
saved his candidacy at the time for what
ad no one really knows and now you know
I feel like I'm in the same place with
the Cruz because there's the the Carson
and the Trump and now the Rubio
campaigns all hidden Cruz over this
there's I don't know how much cursing
you want on your podcast although let's
go this goes out to a bunch of stations
on terrestrial as well yes
charges that they cruises it was
responsible for voter fraud and
basically it's not even well done
charges no it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous putting on the Jewish
lawyer hat on a legal level this is
absurd and and on a moral level it's
absurd to I mean when the news first
broke that ben Carson was skipping Iowa
and New Hampshire and South Carolina and
heading to Florida to pick up his
laundry like there no laundromats in
Manchester North New Hampshire you know
when when that happened everybody on the
Internet's at the same exact thing which
was OK his campaigns over this is just
could you imagine if a white got the
white privilege that would be bandied
about if a white person went back to
Florida to change clothes ben shapiro
were running for office gone i'm going
across the country to change clothes
it's like what your privilege is showing
a google map of all the macy's in town
for for ben Carson and all that and all
the dry cleaners in Manchester for Ben
Carson in case I doubt that out the best
neurosurgeon the country scene shops at
Macy's though John Edwards I don't
remember that John Edwards used to get
these designer suits and he would he
would cut out the tag and put in a fake
like JCPenney tags so he could seem like
one of the people did you know that well
we know the time and we know that Donald
Trump doesn't like Macy's because Macy's
banned his ties and he's tweeted the
made the ties that were made in China
much you correct
what's so certain about this whole thing
with trunk company to get back to
original question is that you know I
started off as kind of lukewarm on Trump
like he's hitting some of the right
people he's a hammer in search of a nail
that means sometimes he hits a nail and
sometimes he hits a puppy but as long as
he's hitting a nail every so often and
then better here than not and then in
the last two months he really just
started to to go wild not just against
Cruz which who cares but but again but
against Cruz on on non conservative
basis so all of a sudden Cruz was a bad
guy because he wasn't in favor of quasi
universal health care Cruz was a bad guy
because he's born in Canada Cruz is a
bad guy because crazy
- right way and nobody liked him in the
Senate like I care if somebody's liked
in the Senate and and this I found
frustrating and as soon as I started
getting critical of Trump then all of a
sudden I started getting exactly what
you've been getting which is all you're
a conservative you're somebody who's
this is because you're a Jew all you
you're Jews coming out and all this
stuff and it's like well first of all my
Jew is always out I mean like I wear
this thing right here this yarmulke I
won't talk a knock we're gonna lose your
Jew powers exactly for those two seconds
right there I was vulnerable but
fortunately I'm in the protection of my
protocols of the only picture like a tea
kettle where you take on the steam goes
out only it's pure cash well that's why
I only take it off in the privacy of my
own home I don't wanna share that cash
no of course not you and your your
secret Jew gold yeah it's it I do feel a
kinship I think with it with the Jews
because I've been the target of so many
anti-semitic comments I mean not not a
Jared knows all the time I'm like what
remember that one time I did that video
on U of M and the guy yelled at me is
some Zionist gulag he said you Jew and I
said I'm not Jewish he was what you look
Jewish and we didn't it didn't make the
cut because we knew that people would
run with us and say was anti-semitic but
what I said to him I said like you meet
a lot of 6-3 225 Jews do you school he
called me a gulag so I don't even know
what people give me the the Jew thing a
lot in my automatic response on Twitter
is yes and huggles say like Jew
exclamation yeah exactly that's when you
look at them and you see exactly where
did you get that where did you get the
first clue was it the name Ben Shapiro I
mean well it think could you come up
with a more Jewish name but you're right
there is a wing of the internet that is
being I would say forwarded by certain
people on the right and they would be
interesting to talk to my law about this
I know Milo and you and I I think you
have differences on this but there's
there's a whole contingent to the alt
right I don't want to say it's the
entire alt Rex I don't know the entire
all right but it's certain it's
certainly a significant percentage of
the all right that the minute he turned
against Trump all of the latent
anti-semitism came out so I was I was
sort of like the the good Jew until I
came out until I started coming out
against Trump and the minute that
happened it was
well he's in the pay of his scientist
master yeah it's like well no all the
people who pay me our Jewish actually
well um what was really bizarre was I
did this thing on first off you're
Jewish okay
Hitler is there anything about Hitler's
policies that were right-wing
conservative yes no no okay exactly I
just want to make sure there's someone
far smarter than me I said I did this
and I wrote about it we talked about the
eighty percent attacks we talked about
the gun control socialized health care
and so he had two responses you had left
us to her furious saying Hitler was a
Hitler was a National Socialist and you
know democratic socialism is still mob
rule which eventually will favor the
Nationalists because they're the
majority right that's the whole problem
with democracy / Republic so they were
really mad saying Hitler was not liberal
and then there's this strong contingency
of people who of course called me are
you a conservative who were mad because
they also want a claim Hitler was not
liberal and that he made Germany great
again
I'm not kidding these are actual tweets
Hitler made Germany great again I've
never seen this before certainly not so
openly and I've talked about this I do
think a big big responsibility this is
from the left the pendulum has by its
nature had to swing further the other
way do you think this is just sort of a
natural reaction to the politically
correct authoritarian speech police a
lot of the people who are
anti-establishment assume they're
conservative because they're
anti-establishment so they look at the
political correct regime that has been
created and their immediate responses I
hate those people so I'll side with the
people on the other side but they're not
necessarily on our side I mean they're
not necessarily conservative a lot of
them are in favor of big government
intervention the economy a lot of them
are in favor of high trade tariffs a lot
of them are earned favor of a tiny
military so I'm not sure what exactly is
so traditionally right-wing about any of
this I mean as far as the National
Socialists thing and the Nazis being
right-wing the truth is that that was a
meme that was originally started by
communists I mean if you're a communist
everybody is right-wing and so by
communist lights the Nazis were
right-wing because if you're on the
extreme left than anything to the right
of you is right but but even but
certainly Hitler didn't consider himself
a right-wing or by any stretch of the
imagination he just considered himself
anti-communist listen Ben and I got both
were pretty young when we got started
when I was the youngest contributor ever
to Fox when I was 21 and my mother said
that Ben
help me with my contract with every
single entity at that point and look you
said and I was a syndicated columnist
when I was 17 and I know that both of us
there you go but for both of us is what
I was saying for people who were trying
to hear what I was saying over the
terrible commercial during the break
what I was actually saying was that you
start off in this movement when you
start off young as an ideologue somebody
who really is a true believer and then
you realize that most of the people in
the movement are actually awful and and
then you sort of become cynical and you
realize so many people are just nasty
and in it to make a buck and then you
you think okay well at election time at
least we'll sort of get our act together
and we'll come back to okay we got to
beat Hillary Clinton we got to find the
most conservative person who can win
we're on the same page and then you just
are disillusioned all over again and it
is massively depressing and it's
happening candidate by candidate and
group by group and it's every time I
think I hate the establishment more I
realized that then I hate the media more
and then I realized that the grassroots
are screwing everyone and it's just it's
terrible and I always have considered
myself an anti-establishment program
oops guy and I still do but I really
feel like this whole thing has just
turned into a massive clown showing it's
depressing
remember when Rubio beat Christie a big
deal that was that was a big
anti-establishment victory and then
people can actually go and look at
footage from years ago where I was
talking to people you know whenever I
would do stand-up comedy that I was open
to this Q&A and I mean I've been doing
stand-up since well I've been doing
stand-up since I was 19
kind of calm but now on the conservative
side people ask these q and A's know
who's the next person and number four
years right was bobby Jindal well not
four years four months and then it was
Marco Rubio and then it was Ted Cruz and
I would always tell them listen it's not
the guy there is no the guy the guy will
always change and I remember actually
about this would have been a year and
three months ago and I was talking to an
audience in Flint Michigan don't drink
the tap water by the way and I said
listen last year you would have said Ted
Marco Rubio was the guy everyone goes no
boo Ted Cruz Ted Cruz this is a room of
about 700 people who came out to watch
this show and now sorry Saint Clair
Shores and I wonder how many of them
right now would say Ted Cruz is the guy
I wonder how many of them would even
admit to having said Ted Cruz is the guy
and I think it's just it's it does come
down to a Messiah Complex
and I do find it somewhat ironic that
the same people who claim that someone
like me who is a conservative or you who
actually just speak on issue whether
it's popular or not who's I signed my
own checks you are you're an
entrepreneur I know you work for some
other companies um at the same time they
call us we cluck servitudes but then get
mad and we speak out against someone who
might be more popular it's it's an irony
that I think is lost on them nothing
that's true I mean it's annoying because
you know again I've defended Trump when
I thought that Trump was right or at
least when I thought he was being
unfairly maligned and I've really I
think done my best to do this penny you
know I don't want this to turn into a
sob session I think that it's more
important to say okay what where can we
go from here and I think that and I'll
be frank with you I am the most
pessimistic person on the right side of
the aisle
I am deeply pessimistic I think that
we're gonna lose the election I think it
doesn't matter who we nominate III come
take the take take a yarmulke off and
see if if you become more positive is
everything bright now whoa like this is
manna people why are we bitching oh wait
like there's there's light in this room
and and I'm feeling sort of sick well
nothing's stuck again yeah that was I
don't know what happened that person
there is no well the Joe Penn is it that
the whole thing is whatever the here's
here's the problem if you want to build
a movement build a movement if you want
to pretend to build a movement do what
you're doing right now because the the
right keeps they've always been like
this we brought an election to election
we just worry about what's right in
front of us and then we lose and then we
say oh well it's true that makes more
urgent that we win the next election so
we have to get the most electable guy we
have to find the I was most electable
and that guy will save us so right in
like really like Reagan on a white horse
it never happens that way Reagan rode in
on a white horse and it still didn't
save the country for a long we're I mean
he delayed sort of the inevitable slide
and the fact is that if you want to
build a movement then you need to start
if we have to here again my custom esta
view if we're going to lose this time
and I don't know that we are but let's
say this agree with very negative
quantities your problem
Blake it up okay is something to go on
here Ben they're looking at you with the
higher IQ to give them hope
the problem is well the reason that I
have the higher IQ then everybody who's
watching is because I don't give you
hope you know and then the prophets gets
stoned in the temple that's how this
works
so it is the the the bottom line here is
that you need to you you do need to
start from the premise that a movement
needs to be built and that movement
needs to be built on ideas not on
temporary coalition's of power because
wait you like this of course you do
you're still here and most people click
off a video in five seconds it's science
we do studies unless there are boobs
they click off the video in five seconds
so thanks for staying click my face to
go to lot or with greater calm where we
do half a dozen new stories every single
day or you may not know this is part of
the full podcast a full 3 hour program
that you can hear every week not only on
radio but click the box right next to me
so you can see the full live version
there's also another video there I don't
know what that is I wouldn't risk it